another major milestone for the biden
presidency he is now failing on all
fronts
the guy who promised competency has
turned into a defective product
americans would like to return biden's
average approval rating dropping below
40 percent for the first time maybe this
is why here's how uh joe is talking
about record inflation
the fact is that we're in a situation
now where
um
you know you should have peace of mind
we're working to bring down prices where
they're not totally what the families in
fact
have to pay now
peace of mind
sounds like his mind is in pieces
and it was probably tough for cnn to
report on these brutal numbers
look at how bad these numbers are for
the president only four in 10 americans
41 at the moment approve of his job
performance nearly six in ten 58
disapproved that's a tough number early
in the midterm election year for the
president united states now why is this
happening this is fascinating we asked
people what has president biden done for
you that you approve of 56 percent of
americans nearly 6 in 10 americans that
means a decent amount of democrats said
nothing they disapprove of everything
that has happened
you know geraldo i am personally
embarrassed by anyone who has to defend
this awful abysmal presidency he should
probably either be impeached or we
should invoke the 25th amendment
i would be personally embarrassed for
anybody who disagreed with that geraldo
personally embarrassed
you sound so
i won't say it
but i will say this
i did it you can't say it he will say
this i will say this
this president you just saw him
struggling to communicate right there
right
a lot of his problem is that he cannot
communicate he is an old man who sounds
like an old man
and when you have problems from
afghanistan to inflation to covet to
everything else to deal with you have to
be able to tell the american people with
verve and elan and and and charisma that
they're going to be okay
and when he talks he tends to look
mumble around to his microphone and look
around and forget the guy's name again
and here and that i think is a lot of
the problem is
his he he may be a very substantive
fellow but he cannot he cannot portray
that
any confidence and we need a confident
president yeah that i would agree with
him
he doesn't instill any confidence judge
i mean the man has never had a plan for
anything yeah he came into office and he
said he was going to unite the country
he didn't unite the country at all and
then you know he said i think it was on
december 10th he said inflation was a
bump in the road well it's about to
crack all our skulls at this point going
forward and the other thing is you know
this man has a socialist plan to solve
america's financial problems okay he's
got a trillion dollar coveted bill
that's not even being used for covert
the latest is they're taking 30 million
dollars out to buy crack pipes to make
them safe to give them away to people
when it should be used for covington
initiative yeah that but but that's a
separate issue
i just want to finish this when asked
what he did that people approve of 56
couldn't think of one thing they approve
of you know why because the guy ran from
the basement the whole thing it was a
trojan horse it was a fraud and you know
what he should have to have some kind of
cognitive test and the 25th amendment
should kick in and that's all i have to
say if we should all volunteer to take a
cognitive i would no i'm not
too risky
too many hits to the head
too many hits of something yes thank you
greg you notice when joe sinks worse and
worse into this this muck
uh jesse the media does more stories on
trump now it's like trump flushed paper
down a toilet that's like raging all
over the other networks the lower jogos
the higher trump goes up on their
headlines yes i really think he's in the
20s and let me explain why it is a crime
to be a democrat president in this day
and age and be anywhere near the 30s you
have soros money you have big tech you
have big labor you have everything
it's like being six foot ten and not
being able to dunk
just you get an inch off the ground and
you're in and he's the man can't get an
inch off the ground you got you white
guys can't jump that's true that is true
i can't even get a half an inch but
that's true that's good stereotyping we
approve of that
what happened here is not only did biden
fall not once not twice but three times
up the stairs not only is his son under
criminal investigation for chinese money
laundering not over is the border wide
open right now
americans lives are so expensive
you put that on top of their more
dangerous and you you have a guy who's
i'm not going to say it like geraldo but
this guy is in so much trouble the
democrats are starting to sound like
republicans they say they want to cut
the gas taxes now
to help americans before the midterms
they'll do anything right
at this point that was those were that
was two very vulnerable democrats mark
kelly and maggie hassan from new
hampshire and arizona because they
realized that they got to do something
because they have to find a way to
separate themselves from president biden
this past weekend after the jobs numbers
on friday were better than people
expected there were all these articles
that ran about joe biden's comeback and
how this was all going to start and then
you had these numbers that came out
today perhaps they lagged but i think
that the cnn numbers those are pretty
bad and it's a very interesting question
that they asked can you name one thing
that he did for you and 56 percent of
people say no the other thing is it's
just our timing is so bad today he
makes abigail spamberger have this event
down in virginia with him
and the the sign behind him is build
back better and says lowering costs for
families on the day
the inflation number was coming out now
they know with the day the inflation
number is coming out you could have like
held that or changed the sign or
something i think this timing is weird
build crack better that was the same how
do you do that
you know but you would speak
speaking of crack we have a hundred
thousand overdoses a year now and it's
almost all fentanyl fentanyl
but if biden actually attacked that an
and
appointed hunter who has a relationship
with china we know and understands drug
addiction to fight the fentanyl scourge
that would be massive that would be
something what do you think dana that's
like one of your ideas i think that's
that's i'm going to put that in my great
point journal thank you thank you i know
joe watches this [ __ ] the sarcasm was
dripping from that i hope it's sarcasm
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else